time-warner monahan monahan
television journal of the implementation
of the aisle broker you every monday
wednesday and friday
a presentation of the laundry list of
all what happened
later on
laundry the world's most are led watch
and what's not
distinguished companion to the world on
ads on gene
good evening
pisses frank night
may i introduce mister william bradford
culated noted author an analyst and
editor in chief of the launching cosco
at mister cochran's press editor of
newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable harold validate
united states congressman from illinois
and chairman of the on american
activities committee
stability is a pleasure to welcome you
click on a scope again
and our viewers of course no u_s_
chairman of the rather pallet
controversial house un-american
activities committee
and tonight
if you tell us something about the
your plans for nineteen fifty three
local band for stardom investigation
welcome mr uranium
mister hinson wonder sure first of all
the news of the great pleasure to be on
your
but very fine program again
as to who first area of investigation
i believe that i think that the rest of
the members of the committee concur with
me in this
than her first movie here's to weed out
the communists and fellow travelers and
people lose their properly known
uh... from the executive branch of
government
any particular partner
well uh...
primarily the state department and the
department of defense
photoreceptor we are able to do that and
i think the
next important thing is true
act as a watchdog committee
do see that uh... no commies are the
server seems of any kind
infiltrate the new eisenhower
administration
the first uh... thing i suppose is
fearing that the
at the holdovers
the people who were in a great in the
previous administration who haven't yet
been discharge from government
uh... intellectually inferior is going
to take quite a long while changeover
control of the executive department
government is going to be a gradual
process i'll show you you mentioned
uh...
that you've been investigating the state
department bank is fairly well known
that you mentioned the defense
department now
r_u_ directing in major investigating
effort at the defense department now
sent to prison turner's worms have been
you know
the very important witness in the
department of defense
and kristen and it's impossible for me
to say anything more about that at this
time
but uh... we do expect to earn a show of
that
several of the
people in the last administration
and uh... where but very close to being
met
communists and
very close to the soviet government do
feel that any of them had uh... apart in
influencing
policy and certainly i do and uh... i
believe that we will be able to prove
that they eventually
important lucy in the defense department
as i think the important policy in the
past and you think these people had
access to uh... to secret information in
the defense department
i need to do believe that is true hannah
and we have and of course uh... in the
past investigations into
the defense department uh...
who've been blown investigations in the
signal corps intelligence in department
and we've been other investigations
uh... well of course was
perhaps remember we had general waller
singlesnet
ahead of the c_i_d_
wrote in philadelphia and said that he
could give us some testimony
in executive session music closed
session and he couldn't possibly give us
in the open session which we were having
at that time
so we have had some investigations into
the defense department refused to
believe that
while it is in june
extremely serious
and that is something that we have to
give our attention to an meted out to
the north goes and you anticipate taking
up
for example the room
we didn't see any has been infiltrated
or certainly certain about his saving
the central intelligence yes that's
right
nasser one of the
you say that you want to protect the
u_s_ inherit ministration from
subversives
uh... do you expect to get day higher
degree of cooperation from the
eisenhower administration did you get
from the truman administration
certainly but when i say that uh... to
protect the uh...
eisenhower administration i don't mean
that in a political way i think the
protection of the eisenhower
administration will certainly be a
protection of the american
but they're not there to do
expect to
and as we in congress
in the legislative branch do expect to
get a lot more cooperation
from the executive branch isn't
listening in the past
specifically on the matter of uh... i
remember that
our viewers will remember that uh...
president truman repeatedly refused to
turn over to certain executive files
that you do you think the president
eisenhower will make those executive
sounds of able to u yes but i understand
i don't believe that uh... president
eisenhower
mr j under hoover mister brown ale
or continuing unit captain and he is
should be all of their information
through the legislative branch there is
certainly judo school
you know i i i i didn't personally want
to ask for anything that i didn't think
they could give
uniform referring to is the loyalty
files of the
various departments in the executive
branch i believe that you know jim and
access to those
now the committee itself of course is
that uh...
as i say a very controversial career
nowadays that martin diets with his
first chairman
now do you feel that the committee today
it has that a degree of public support
that has never had
yes i do from all the letters that uh...
come into our committee in the coming
through to me you know i was in the day
unit we may have uh... by far great
majority and i would just be asked about
ninety percent of them are
favorable to the work that the american
activities committee has been wooing the
problem do you still have been in public
acceptance of the work if any problem
well there are always so you know uh...
level
people
who've never accepted me
program let me undertake handed because
it might affect them and you know do you
have a lot of left-wingers a lot of
uh...
phillip it was a lot of people who ruled
object to anything we do regardless of
what it is
what about and what about uh... money he
did your committee spend more money than
any of the committee
and congress seems to do
when was the smallest committing
membership we don't have my members on
the unamerican activities committee
really needs to happen soon numbers into
the fifties
than unnerve corporation in which we're
going to ask for this year's three
hundred thousand therefore unless there
is nothing seems to be fifteen thousand
hours more than that we used last year
karoon unbelievable committees of the
congress do not have the same
problematic with
as presented to us uh...
lemkin
from the extensive files as we keep them
i want to say here now that
all of our files
too
an inspection bunbury western
intelligence agencies of the executive
branch including ninety nine is along
with them
certainly do-able
and uh... we intend to continue
routine who is a man with a member of
cooperating with an addition to the
investigation of the defense department
and leave it at
the most controversial finger about to
do is some investigation of
timbers of their lives subversive
activities in the colleges
do you expect to get around to the
educational system of this year you know
some of the first witness is we will
call
there will be in
professors and people who are interested
in indication
i want to say
that brian lawrence we have had the
cooperation
paid great number of universities and
colleges throughout the country they
want to know foods and you know
subversive influence is operating in
there
individual at colleges and universities
but what about the objection the loyalty
oaths and university
who is a considerable objection to a
little too many of those states uh...
remember when we do have a new american
association of university professors and
which is a very ripples organization
unwilling to reason to object june
loyalty oaths
but i believe that one
we'll conclude our investigation member
hearings
and then burned for me in this
uh... the uh... a lot of people who have
had objection
concerning
meet loyalty oaths who have been a lot
of these loyalty oaths of workable
efficiently what the exactly who they
achieve in university
really good
you know certainly uh... when the
person's surrounds me
uh... loyalty co-author which is
someone similar to me how non-printing
area
non-communist affidavit under the tent
hardware
recruitment points uh... before he signs
that
both uh... for fear of being
the prosecutor perjury
local resigned
and i'll show you what you were with the
f_b_i_ before you went to congress or
something opinion in sri lanka legends
of the country
who mostly in fifteen minutes to restore
international continue feel that there
is
more or less communist activity in the
united states today
there's a growing or is it uh...
becoming less probably the actual
communist activity has uh... become less
and at several years and has been
uh... since nineteen and quality and
quantity
well it's important to you mean possibly
wanting quantity and he was still a very
real
immediate danger
and the uh... infiltration
then
comes from your personal are controlled
by the soviets
hidden
andrea soon
moves in
uh... from institutions in on your
investigation of education
you feel that you have the cooperation
of most of the educational institution
dot do you think the teachers
organizations will
were resistor investigating on the one
you control certain i didn't think that
we will have the cooperation of the
great
to majority of our educational
institutions
former state first of all that they were
not concentrating on anyone individual
institution
except lows direct communist schools for
instance the
link to
the california labor school of jefferson
school
or was cool
what you're going to increase labor and
communism directly
and undergrowth implements independence
party
and has a final question sir
if you don't feel that
that you're going to rally
civil rights in this investigation
thrillers and possibility that we might
uh... in some cases uh...
police admit being with your opinion
that we are willing to civil rights
especially
in and we do appear that we won't be
denies it comes to films well thank you
very much for being with us this evening
sick
when your insurer
behavioral figures expressed tonight
lebanon colleen at all
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promise felt was mister
william bradford hilly and mister kyle
this
our distinguished guests was the
honorable harold velvet united states
congressman from illinois and chairman
of the unamerican activities committee
how would you go about hiring amanpour
an important job
when a man or in a box a record of past
performance of the ambiance pictorial
vendio
that's why so many sensible people all
monte mopped
illness was launching lots of walk off
the record of past performance
these worlds fairground prizes and gold
medals each a higher for the where
bestowed by many men men many lands that
many times
observatory accuracy awards one just
yesterday so to speak are also part of
the lawn jean grecko
from the river there could be moved up
that launching watches are above and
beyond the og
for almost a hundred years
long gene has been shown to be close to
the finest watching all the world
by every standard
beauty integrity of manufacture accuracy
and reliability of performance
the long been refered made launching the
world's most haunted watch
the world's most on again
flaunting
premium product of the laundry macmall
opt out
since eighteen sixty six
maker of waters of the highest debt
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long dream comes true
a television journal of the important
this is where they are
broadcast on the cop of launching the
world's most honored watch
and whatnot distinguished companion
for the world ahmed launching
this is right now
reminding you that long g_-men would not
want to
are sold out of service from coast to
coast
by more than four thousand leading
killer
proudly display their family
agency wall long-chain mcnaught
time for the lawn games on it
television journal of the implementation
of the aisle
partial you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on
laundry the world's most are led watch
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
ads on g
good evening that the fact that
man and reduce our quoted us for this
edition of the laundry brownsville
mister william bradford delayed at a
time of the american workers
and mister henry has left
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable gilday stop junior
united states representative from
pennsylvania
the opinions expressed
are necessarily those of the speaker
congressman scott his former head of the
republican national committee
and that is one of the architects of the
eisenhower campaign
i'd like to begin by asking you
plans a campaign going to start
tomorrow
about the middle of the day would say
eisenhower makes an important speech in
atlanta georgia
that will be followed by speeches in
other florida's in florida cities
in alabama
in arkansas and then by their important
foreign policy speech in philadelphia on
the fourth
september could you tell us what topics
you going to speak on us
on these for speech is better for their
free speech he will talk generally on a
mass in washington what he thinks about
it uh... with some specific instances
and uh... i am quite sure what because
uh...
have some advance information that they
will be very forthright
fighting
here meetings with governor stevenson
there is a mess in washington
well i'm sure a breeze of governors to
exam that is a mess in washington i'm
sure that he is very angry about it as a
in morro uh...
in the way in which he prepares his
speeches and i think we're going to get
the benefit of that
this bs fight after all as i see it
is against it
harry truman's
that government and harry truman's
captive canada
and harry truman's having taken great
leadership of this campaign
stevenson's a secondary issue uh...
truman in his uh...
the milwaukee labor day speech you
recall that
azeri
as said in a practice stevenson what
shall i do it on the boss are run this
thing and you take your lead from his do
you think the battle from the former
owner of the essentially between uh...
president truman and general eisenhower
by doing so because i don't think that
uh...
instrument could keep out of it don't
think that uh... issue of truman as im
which is equivalent to bad government
could possibly be kept out of it
and i think that uh... mister truman's
captive cavities just stuck
with harry
do you think that uh... there have been
the feeling it
general eisenhower first
could not effectively make the case
against the democratic
friday and then second that probably he
would not make the case now you can't
answer after your weeks if you spend
with him
agenda last now is going to prosecute
the case against the democratic party
yes i'm satisfied that he's going to
prosecute a case against the president
administration which goes under the
title of democratic visits
is not a democrat for democratic
competitors truman as a
it's a mess so that's what do you think
that it's been a statement that he would
not resort personalities now that the
president has attacked him
do you think that he will uh... at least
resort to the press to the personality
of the president i think that he can
attack this whole thing that's wrong
without necessarily calling anybody any
bad names because they
the battle order
and the bad names have already been
established an eight his job to find out
what's wrong
the government in power
let's take one of the personality as
namely the secretary of state
i believe that
the
persistence is on record as having said
that he didn't have the faintest idea of
whether he would uh... describes the
status of the night
do you think that general eisenhower has
has a something of the farmer had the
rest of course of action there
i don't think there's a singled out in
the world
the madison worse
the work of stupid enough or foolish
enough to read maybe an obvious next
january
that he would be final question he'd be
fine but i think at december resign on
me
first wednesday after the first used in
the military but an american voters
the extent
can then make a choice on that point
if you have to tears it
stevenson he doesn't know whether you
get rid of that this is that if you wish
to use that in our he knows he's
yesterday met captive and the victim of
men who are pretty smart and among those
men are being that person
who has control of foreign policy of
this country to it
soviet
man who has led us down the road to
weakness in the face of jeremy
vandalism
hesitated
to deal
with those who are enemies of our
government every week need
monte carlo
uh... milk and water fresh in the man
has doctor golden eisenhower there's no
question you go on the stevens and i
don't think stevenson
is that
is in a position where you can get red
of these old men of the cd that have
been playing to the the democratic ship
well general eisenhower
has said that some terrible blunders
were made in korea
in are getting into career
now is he going to spell out in detail
what those blunders warranted
uh... unlimited
quite sure whether the is going to spell
them out because he will make several
speeches on foreign policy and one of
the men ever to be more than one
would have to deal
with the kind of a war that we've gotten
into which we can leave the wind
knows
nonstop
unlimited trail runners labor day speech
spoke of all those people who have
benefited so much
uh... from uh...
as he said from a on higher wage
i can't think of a hundred and thirty
seven thousand gag orders in korea
whomever benefit
from anything that mister truman has
docked in general eisenhower going to
defend the taft hartley act against the
attacks of stevens and and uh...
the president
i think that uh... generalized knowledge
likely take the position and i cannot
undertake obviously speak for him but
i'm we have
that he would take the
republican position which is that the
labor management act
nineteen forty-seven
operates family in the interest of
people who
laurin labor union labor or not you know
it
i think uh...
again mister truman has given us the key
to it but he points out that union labor
used to have three million people
simply labor management act all the taft
hartley act of nineteen forty seven out
sixty million people in unit
all of them boilerplate
all of them with their living conditions
but they're probably right because there
is a good bit of an accident of his work
to the advantage of labels and how the
majority of democrats in congress think
about these attacks on the taft hartley
act
in the majority vote of the house and of
the senate
hope for the tax hartley act on speaking
on the democratic majority the alleged
to have got my recollection that they
did yet predicted
and then they also majority in congress
also recommend or express the hope that
the president will deal with the taft
hartley act in the steel strike and of
course of course they did and that more
than that you're interested in the
overall incident the the
of the house labor committee was mister
brzezinski at michigan
list of those killed one celebrate
occasion said to one of the republican
members of the committee we are not
going to do anything to repeal
taft-hartley ought to change it
because we're going to have it as a
major
will do anything about it and that's mr
truman's position and necessary
i have to be with the stevenson's
position if he were to be the chief
executive
that's just got a great deal has been
said about uh... errors in the
eisenhower campaign thus far
as one of the have nots strategist do
you think that there have been a
resident of the camp
why it before so it's uh...
factor wise problems for the democratic
national committee
i think they've made it quite a few
erisa
there must have been working very hard
at it in a short time a pet
uh... the the uh...
cabinet meeting
which showed that this is a must go to
washington to get his daughters from
harry
was one instance i think that show that
they
the hand there is the end of the
weiss's avoid subjective at the end of
the end of the saudi remember that was a
hand
mandate through the voices of or is it a
bit
and wave their hands terry
on our program last
mistook him for a limited summary
critical statements about that somehow
or campaign before you go on receive
periodic or mentioned above
blunder and that was the fact that
stevenson
uh... admits that there is a mess in
washington now
he's going to try to back away from it
but he said it
and uh... he's good at the six syllable
words bring somewhat of a four-letter
word misleads well over the whole
mister froggy however made some
definite predictions
as and has he has a reputation as a
predictor i believe
tonight uh... i'm sure that i viewers
would like for you to predict
the way that you
i think the campaign will develop in the
way the nation ruble
well if you think eisenhower
specifically who has a chance to get a
seven states
who are not you know
components that make it to predict there
but i did predict that i've now with the
reader in his apartment on the first
ballot by albert brooks a month
predicted that too
use film in a month before an element of
two five five
uh... i i would say that if i'm a
venture in the phone three oh
that eisenhower
will win
that he will carry several southern
states that he will
have the support
all groups and classes in crimes in
conditions of americans because he's not
a sectarian
for a section of the credit
defending national karen
became amos southend space if you think
general eisenhower can carry
i think it might be unfair to those
people who are working so hard in all
the southern states to put the finger is
commonly said that among those are
probably junior
texas
uh... i would think that louisiana
elicited mensa reaction against the tide
land situation would be one florida and
or others well general eisenhower take
the position of texas on the title and
case okay
position that uh...
shivers believe and well i i must admit
that he has a
substantially taken this position of
texas had a treaty with the united
states texas reserve the right to the
that all of its land including those
offshore
and the united states are not to break
any treaty
including one with texas the texans
don't like it either or whomever that
but as i understand you sir
you're one of those
supporters of the eisenhower whose
completely convinced that the general
will carry on a very forthright smoking
campaign from this point yes i'm
satisfied averages a higher monday jim
for the other day that uh...
maxim which he may have invented that
you never campaign with straw hat
naturally those people who want un's
mouth to win
and there's so many of them are anxious
for him to get started early with labor
day is here
usually the start of the campaign
you expected to start work thank you
very much for being with us tonight
there's this guy
the editorial board for this edition of
the mounting problems go flaws
mister william bradford killing and
mister henry have
our distinguished guests closely on
overview would be stopped
united states representative from
pennsylvania
east or west
no other name on a lot means so much as
laundry
the world's most powerful
activated lunging watches are sold in
service
in all the capitals of the free world
the appreciation of things fine and
beautiful
universal
judging by the same high standards
known as the people the world over agree
that long gene watches are in favor of
respect
where they are but then world's fair
grand prizes
and twenty eight gold medal
which impartial juries of express have
bestowed upon them for elegance and
excellence
it was through superior met
that smoking became in fact
the world's most on a block
uh... whichever launching walk you
choose to make your own
rest assured
it will bring you were in full measure
for greater actors
and longer life public flogging watches
are world on it
yet unbelievably you made by a dog
although i can probably get the logging
walked
for as little as seventy one fifty
long jane the world's most
premium product of the long teen but not
what company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of lots of of the highest debt
we invited to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time fall along being promised
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
broadcast on the comp of laundry
smalls all night long
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world dot
i don't see
business right now
reminding you of that long game and with
a lot
hospitals and service from coast to
coast
by more than four thousand leaving do it
proudly display their them
patron saint paul daunting with norwalk
the oral on the artwork walk off we all
morning
plunging watches have one can work
program prices forty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other countries
launching the world's most honored
watches made and guaranteed by the
laundry with more what company
times on the launching promised us
television journal of the
implementations of the aisle
partial you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of a laundry list of all
what happened
later on
long james the world's most al-kidwa
and what's not distinguished companion
to the world on and on gene
good evening
this is frank dot
may i introduce our calendars for this
edition of the mounting products co
mister henry steiger editor of argosy
magazine
and mister william bradford purely
editor of the american market
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable judy stopped doing a
united states representative from
pennsylvania
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
silently in support of snow here is a
man whose supporting a great deal of
time to promoting the candidacy of
general eisenhower
now obviously you think you're going to
have an active candidate so we want to
ask you those old questions about prove
whether or not you think you're going to
run
that we would be interested in your
interpretation of general of what you
think will be general and i was
positions
now sir
do you believe that general admin our
expects to wage
eight and active campaign and expresses
opinions on all the violation
i would certainly expect that the other
side
i have heard him say on occasion that
when not in uniform have never had any
hesitation in expressing himself
vigorously on the issues of the day
and i've heard him used the expression
uh... the american people will be a no
doubt
store and i stand on an important matter
do you think that he's too good an
american
to expect to be given the nomination
while the people are still in doubt as
to where he stands
i think he would feel
that the american people are entitled to
know
from not only his past speeches but from
his
future comments exactly where you stand
on matters of great importance them and
i think
uh... that long before the time that
people will have to act they will be
fully aware
of his views stated without equivocation
now there are many good americans who
are bitterly opposed to the candidacy of
general eisenhower's
southwestern slept st p_e_ their there
points that they make against him
number one they say that he has no
stomach for controversy what your
opinion on that ship but i think that's
that is ridiculous vetting statement
i've ever heard because
uh... to know
generalizing has to know that
he has never hesitate to
lay down the law ought to express his
opinion sir
as he sees them and i know some of the
things he's had to say the foreign
governments
i know of one celebrated difference of
opinion with churchill for example
and now there's nothing wrong with that
man what about tomorrow either speaking
of intestinal fortitude how about uh...
such ordinary everyday things is uh...
we've even heard of it talk about his
week stomach uh... literally speaking
well i i was there when they were
married
some government just spread that there
are more of a sort of smear
and they said to me the only thing that
has bothered me the whole time i've been
in europe has been the fact this morning
i have a cold and wet
and uh...
that day you may have to go to great
eighteen holes of golf which is part of
the work it out
to play golf every word that governments
evolved into work after that
certainly deserves
strong-arm
veroa man don't be met by now that they
come on about that
is heading restrain general patton he's
having uh...
uh... generally approving cooperate with
russia policy nineteen forty five forty
six
is having supported the morgan felt plan
now why do you believe that uh...
general eisenhower favored be cooperate
with russia plan in nineteen forty five
msexch
belong on the contrary i would be
inclined very strongly to believe what
you will find for yourself in the parcel
barriers
page seventy six israelis net web page
two sixty borders exp fire rated shows
that
wrap our story points that i can have a
right definitely came to grips with
checkout
that he complained against the fixing
about liability awarded to proceed as
far as our military potential will
permit
and then another thing the president not
a place in the part of ours
he expressed grave mistrust of giving
any concession away to the russians
at the forthcoming elmer conference and
said the church you know i hope
it will not
major concessions to the russians
because they can't be trusted about
specifically the eight months got uh...
there was some talk you know about
sharing that with russia at the time of
nineteen forty five
forces what was his uh... thought there
highlight
i could not uh... answer of my own
daughter because i'm not familiar with
the controversy but i've you know
that is general distrust
of communist
his hatred of communism in his distrust
of russia
would never have a lot of general
eisenhower to
constraint for a moment with a bomb or
to be shared their reflection on my part
of his views in the korean war
where he is reluctant to give the as a
military weapon unless and until there
is no other alternative
now that you mentioned the altar moment
no sir
number one it your opinion that general
eisenhower was consulted before the all
the conference
it's my opinion that uh... he was
consulted generally
on military and diplomatic matters and
that he did express himself as far as
the reports that he did as being very
mistrustful of the russians and
hopefully a majority would be your
opinion that he would have been opposed
to the concessions made that president
roosevelt to russia at the office
very definitely feel that and i had and
i know of very recent conversations how
much he
hates and fear of communism and how
anxiously is that the american people
respect for the young people
will become aware of the dreadful in
morocco menace which communism is it
your belief that he understands the
nature of the communist conspiracy
throughout the world and that he wasn't
allowed in and out of the speaker is no
other members in my opinion and i think
he has a formal
faulty american
way of life of the democratic play for
the full weight of the collective
security every word i hope to the scene
here in the united states it's often
said that
disturbing favored by the truman
administration of some indication of my
pictures of that how do you feel about
that
writing about that
which the general wrote to someone on a
first-name basis
not so long ago in which he said
i have never then responsible for larsen
and responsibility for the positive
attitude ministration any administration
during the forty years
which had been in the army
the most american exactly after that
i'll show you know i know he's creative
to combat uh... the things with which
you disagree is not would include
a lot of truman ism
is irate
uh... i i don't know if personal trainer
but i don't see how r
he could go along with the age at a
policy
and i know many of the strongest chris
critics of the age and it caused a who
have
talk to the general have been expressed
themselves as entirely satisfied
would like i've announced he was on the
adriatic paul how most people who are
you wouldn't favor a trucking toward
communism only
ania peace now most americans who are
andy administrations they wanted battle
in nineteen fifty two
i think that they lost
to truman in nineteen forty eight
because they didn't have a scripting
candidate
cited your convictions are that if they
nominate general eisenhower they will
get that real suspecting candidate
another not another meeting candidate
was not going to say to you mister here
and to the people in this television
audience
but if a new general eisenhower as i'm
alan and as many other people who know
him better than i do
are aware of
there's no question of the fact that
there is much that goes on in our
government in domestic and foreign
affairs
which he will feel free to criticize
which we will criticize mister pinkwater
fight
my god i will get them because of an
awful lot but
i hate about this administration and i
think that's it
general views are those of a good
minded middle-of-the-road republican
about the macarthur fight and i would
expect him to do the same
in other was a lot of talk about uh... i
said are in my pocket being at odds
could you clear that up i'd like to know
how they feel about each other
well i i i don't uh... i can't
compuserve said how one man feels about
another attorneys mine and i don't know
but i did all that
that so far as i have any information
hold each other in america
and if each of the bags as much of the
other as i think of both of them
or there can be no cause for the state
controversy with your few people would
like to throw out he got to go up as a
great night
and i guys now is a great man among
great man i find a mutual respect
for that capacity well i think that
eisenhower is such a fighting man is he
going to come up pretty soon and and
uh...
and uh... state his candidacy in further
are so we're going to find out about
i think that is
the question which your only got
going to get answered by general regard
himself but i would expect
of long before the convention
he will be in civilian life again out of
uniform
and for you had to these question about
salary and how about in march mr simon
you know we've got that would be a bit
surprised you happen to have shipped
primary on march eleven february could
happen in market will depend upon the
completion of his job
i think that that most of our debt you
would like to be interested in your
answer to this question
suppose general eisenhower does campaign
for the republican nomination
and suppose for some reason he loses it
do you think that he would then support
the republican
in a campaign of nineteen fifty two i've
said that i'm charlie convinced that
he's a republican
therefore i applied that standard
i'm sure all of that no matter how we
made the phone now with after the
convention
all of us will be united to get rid of
this
violence administered has come to be
known as truman as a man i would expect
any other republican which would include
the their eisenhower into their life
would feel the same way
you
do you think that general eisenhower
neelu ruled support in america do
yourself
consider yourself a liberal as it's now
used an american politics
uh...
i don't think that uh... you know
i got to know myself
would want to use the word never
overestimate what it meant that i have a
quotation from heaven which he said the
definition of a member of the camera man
in washington
wants to play the almighty without money
no it's not that kind of a level and i
think you'd be very careful with the
pocketbook in the press strings of the
government
eyes if you'll be in a progressive
a modern minded met on the road
mid-century american who share the
apprehensions of other apprehensive
americans yes and i hope i'm that kind i
guess they realize that ideas are very
much for coming out
lead editorial board for this edition of
the launching promise no one's
mister henry speaker and mister william
bradford julie
our distinguished guests will be audible
jude's stopped doing a united states
represented of from pennsylvania
four thousand leading to the lives of
the united states will answer your
question
what is the finest watch yourself
with the answer my finest is launching
now is not a compelling consideration
when planning the bridges alva watch
as a christmas gift as a matter of fact
throughout the world in such places
asap
story seat of learning macaroni descent
through the muslim world
in bangkok capital city of dot and the
and since i a m
or andropov
the sky high capital of bolivia as in
all capitals of all three nations
no other name on a christmas watch
means so much as launching
the world's most on it well
they all day watching history to end to
end welfare brownbrothers
twenty eight gold medal awards and
highest honors for accuracy from the
great government observatory
there's a style and type of long team
lots
for every need input
faultless we finished
styles with ageless good faith
made with the speed of eighty five years
of find what's making experience
to be a good time for a long long time
and do you know that you laid by and
probably give a motive watch
this christmas
for as little as seventy one fifty
holding the world's most all is well
premium product for the long teen but
not what's happening
james eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all of the highest
frank night again inviting you to join
us every monday wednesday and friday
evening
at the same time
father logging pronto
a television journal of the important
issues that they are
broadcast on behalf of laundry
the world's most on edline
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world ahmed launching
so that if they have a from coast to
coast
by more than four thousand speaking to
us
who proudly display their family
agency pall mall jean what na locked
hai
the
on or part
online
plunging watchers have one camera for a
grand prizes forty eight gold medals and
moreover for accuracy than any other
party
probably the world's most honored
watchers made and guaranteed by the
loaded with my wife company
planned for the probably
television journal of the important in
terms of the hour hostile you every
monday wednesday and friday
presentation of a laundry list of all
what happened
later on
launching the world's most common law
and with
distinguished companions of the world on
a daunting
remain but the fact that
narendra deals are co-editors elizabeth
involved along involved
that they were here at the killings
editor of the american workers
and that they have remarked editor of
the freemen and contributing editor or
for newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening if the honorable john blvd
it's a stronger from from in the apt
the opinions expressed
are necessarily those of the figures
within the review where representatives
intrigue i believe in indiana
and that is the wrong wouldn't pull
who's now on the basis of walk in prison
non-financial interests are harmful
audiences gravely concerned
about the fate of americans abroad and
speaking of americans and warm and i'd
like you could tell us some of the
background of that case
he has prepared for it
village
seems to me in the end of week to do
progress in the business that i had the
privilege for everything
in fact really the only twenty miles
from my home town of all taxes on the
backs of all that
c_n_n_'s ralph wenge
decided that
junior of the newspapers and the
part of the disappearance of builders
and indeed in the art began to repeat
telephone call
and telegram from the people needed to
get convicted
himself reported to be prepared to do
that by pierre had disappeared consensus
on but in fact he would be turned over
their heads and so she did
learned that he was arrested
i think was on the following david
twenty-six reported that he had been
improvement
and it was very animated i can produce
resolution in bisbee
thanks i introduced government that
president clinton has other members of
congress to do likewise
enough said that's of course is just
another one of the
americans have been an effect grabbed it
that these russian satellite countries
that's correct
we definitely juliet repaired twice in
the people back home after all builders
that's another person with the new
threatened poppy plant
ransom purposes
as many of the problem very simply
before the grand canyon
deposit
the nation's alone
so in europe
and then uh... just for training
purposes the on the case against the
navy's number contained barone's
beautifully advises against us well of
course he said he was
sign this he was
mine and he was really getting new clean
any other movement
what it would be i mean if you would
find a lot of people look
could be a not a mockery of the trial of
food and they have a if they have it
but matters
none of the american uh... uh... the
embassy officials were politically isn't
it
yet they think they have a confession
from whales the chances are in the
report seemed quite true that he was
tortured
method of bringing the confession from
him with secured but net message
by the way i might say that at the trial
the only to americans
fitted at the back of the room
and so we do have a transcript of the
property taken for him
one woman secretary but what was
actually talked again for meeting with
that isn't going to be a bit
corresponded more or less getting there
was little doubt about it
from their point of view however did not
get the move directly from their four
children
public servant of propaganda isn't all
that certainly within the movement
are audience
them can understand that there is an
american do indeed beauty and and and a
foreign country suddenly season thrown
into jail in subject the pocket now the
question becomes what can we do and what
are we doing about it it will be a lot
like to get wanted to tell us first of
all over
what background was and wanted actually
has been done it had not been done
now contraceptive resolution of your
did not actors and market that provides
their resolution which would help doing
concurrent resolution two hundred and
fourteen
assistant to the congress that they
trade relations with
czechoslovakian other ways to improve
the economic
it doesn't have anything to do at that
time with the seventh of diplomatic
relations
and that the state department to
anything affective along that line will
they employ effort we might truly
believe that the featured length with
hillary clinton presenter book september
intending to put on the fact that we
have booked
purity
that constitutes a trade mission
with respect to the fact of life part of
course
sever their relations with
linguistic
undergoing
really going to love him on trademe care
i might and for the wave we haven't had
very much for granted
attentive at the facts about me never
dealt with it
audits at failed for the millions of
lives of all thanks for your review
already the americans last april
therefore
can we do
as a nation in west lafayette louisiana
and recommended a new york ny resolution
one course of action
what about uh... severing
diplomatic relations with these people
well at that time it was
self-interest
bettered part of wisdom
they're part of our words of wisdom that
might be good
having another method
to use another two weeks than others
bring to a bull in other words
economic sanctions that were proposed by
this resolution if they did not to go to
the top
abandoned
a proposal to institute reputed
institutes ever relations with
type of uh... younger and your effort
said to get through
loaded his release
uh... have you had uh... cooperation
satisfactory cooperation from the state
department
franklin
i have had beer i'd spielberg
cooperation
they have to do that
certain things have been done rather
never the turn of the night
still think the report you've approved
have reported to me
what's the matter is if we could get it
some changes for freedom of movement
complete and correct the difference
i want to point out to you live in
nineteen hundred and fifty one
several months
waiting for that matter when they put
corporations
still imported more merchandise united
states
that was important
wire your like two hundred and forty
nine and nearly as much of the important
making hundred and fifty
says that we haven't been looking at one
point thirty six now i have
seeing all this economy for asking
for a formal grant
form of blackmail feeling today
was started
what does that fit your pattern that
finally whispering that will be uh...
they have two hundred and twenty
thousand level is for the forum format
motivator for flyers were put down in
the
would remember the bulletin
we had a meeting for a day in trying to
make a trade i don't know that marvelous
finalists of motive
forces stationed there will be put in
prison for seventeen one and uh... i
believe this is true surveyed mr barbour
credit for his relates to the press into
his life
and there's no credit for the state
department figures released a lesser
extent breakthrough in fact this is the
man i had the pleasure of meeting and
during a meeting with mister mister
robert wolders
and the very impressive
visit methods that are going to mess
with older who
work untimely non-fiction before his
release
but also to the press and the review
country best
wavered in his big performance in the
new place the order of payment from the
game for
resources needed to what we were in for
the four american flying
i with the
state emphatically no overtime they
rejected this republic when
we were very small
and we could play brinkmanship here
who's the harrison ford reports
being the main even then remember the
president said that if you do with it
more leadership
stock with that type of recovery
i think it's quite believe our dignity
even considered incurable and i'd like
to have to look forward to form a
seemingly weaponry
without breaking off
diplomatic relations
repetitive on c_n_n_
why should we concluded that the
nation's walkable get out of the doubt
outside of humiliation and insult
and the things we need to do nothing
about represented there
and the irish
penises
given or rather the reason that they
can't get me in some instances
this isn't as long as we have a
diplomatic relations there in the
country we do have the people
in the validity of this
things of that argument
provided wonderful if they're getting a
raw oysters
feeding the method of putting up with me
close here by the same token haven't
they wanted and over forty four
witnesses but a milestone for them not
all that the bank that's everything they
wanted to have access over their heads
to everything and while there were a kid
and fifty extremely safe in uh... in
those countries or a representative of
the intended recipient of the number of
employees
and and and and you just think about it
there are ways by which we could hit
them in the pocketbook
that we are not using isn't that correct
procurement through one of the movement
probably isn't
flowed from the fact is saying is
vessels on the possible for them
we meet our american dollars
first of all would be
well for the region currently
and the need for the propaganda purposes
these impressive
propaganda thinking that what you're
doing
but extensively
i think now sir our eyes and selected
voters agency on the way they got out of
hollywood because the american press in
american people
that enough
i suppose that some of our listeners
would like to have yet they'll notice
out
what can i just couldn't believe the
defendants as a practical matter het wel
there are a lot of things president for
you
because in that figure right for me i'm
working
along with that kind of neglect cannot
receive letter community many other i
waited every
who's interested in the business
community
and we'll return after all we are in a
row
notices more message symbols of a given
man anymore he's a symbol of freedom of
incomplete without being put on the line
i'd like for every person right to
present for women to secretary of state
action memphis
as he speaks in positive action rather
than just back from the reform
validation very much appreciated
the here newsies tonight and thank you
for being with us
the editorial board for the position of
the launching carlos beltran
mister william bradford killing
and mister henry have
our distinguished guests was the
honorable john blvd united states
congressman from india
winter olympic games recently completed
in oslo were actively time by logging
do want them
and the hundreds of
arora
plaza telegraph
logging equipment used for all of
timekeeping during the winter olympic
games of nineteen fifty two
for work
thanks for your valuable cooperation
signed the organizing committee
now that the wonderful telegram
and wrong
from james was actually official watch
for the three grades
exports of end of the year
the winter olympic games alpha
prepared for the very end game
progressives in venezuela
and the first on american games held in
blood are even our computer
and i were proud to announce
that the united states olympic committee
has selected logging waters
for signing all of them
for the direction of the united states
olympic team of nineteen fifty two
so you see wherever website timing is
important
sometime
the preeminent choice of water
is launching
they only want in history
fluent and welfare grand prizes
twenty eight co levels
and higher power for accuracy from the
leading government services
long day in the world
premium product of the long game of golf
since eighteen
make a profit
of the highest
we invited to join a every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
all along the info
developing developing important then to
the payoff
broadcast on behalf of not being in the
world most ahmedabad
and with no i don't think we've
companion to the world
bankunited reminding you that loan
demand but now i want to
ourselves and forever from coast to
coast
by more than four thousand leaving here
on earth
who proudly displays a cameraman
hazen paper on on being written off
leave or on the locked leave in
plunging watches have one can work
program prices twenty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other time fees
launching the world's most honored
watches made and guaranteed by the
launching with more watch company
its timing for along gene product
type television journal of the vital of
them so they are
brought to you three times weekly
a presentation of the lawn jamie what
norwalk stopped
maker on launching the world's most on
it lots
and what not
distinguished companion to the world on
it on g
good evening this is ranked nine th
man produce article editors for this
edition of the launching prosto
doctor young from ac
formerly ambassador from czechoslovakia
and member of the advisory committee of
the united nations
mister william bradford puri
editor of the american mercury
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable alternate armstrong
united states congressman from missouri
in this fontaine yes and unrehearsed
discussion
the opinions on essar allay those are
the speakers
congressman uh... uh
endeavours
listeners will remember nearly four
years rendered story is not a cousin
reader's digest
i believe you are you're from the
missouri ozarks aren't you
that i personally i live in springfield
missouri and i thrive in the middle of
the ozarks
and uh...
your republican from that state there
are national leader dot
i'm uh... republican
where we would be a progressive
republican nicely
the nice there where
an r and r list miserably most
interested
and what you're doing in congress your
efforts to free the splendid american
journalist bill moyers
now out
how did you come to champion uh... date
mister ortiz
well mister healy uh... being a
journalist uh... myself former
newspaperman magazine writer
i hear was uh... connected with the idea
that something should be done
when the communist regime of
czechoslovakia imprison this man
uh... simply because as we felt that he
was going about his duty
so i a m produced an amendment to a
resolution in congress
which called upon our government to
ah... cut off trade relations with a
communist regime of czechoslovakia
unless he is free
you are of course convinced of
resolution innocent of all it's charges
have been made against him
all yes indeed and i'm sure um... the
uh... my colleagues in congress agreed
on that
uh...
and uh...
but uh... what steps
have have now been taken to free the
students
uh... while mister he laid out in
the resolution which was passed by
congress
uh... calls upon our government
to break trade relations which acts as a
voc ea
unless mister ellipses free
now that resolution was passed uh...
i'll believe doctor happen etc you will
recall the date the passages up that
resolution
it was named
alarms
we sleep well at any rate doctor since
that time
uh... considerable pressure has been the
what on the czechoslovakian government
as you know
uh... to free this uh... american
newspaper correspondent
but unsuccessfully
now we think it is time to put in the
book what all the pressure that we can
jargon free
what particular steps have been taken
prior to your actions
prior to the action all congress on my
resolution
uh... the president the secretary of
state and others in the executive
departments have made some moves
uh... to free mister elvis those moves
were for the most part
we felt her at least a great many others
in congress felt that they were just
laughs all the rest
ever not strong enough
and therefore we went ahead with this
resolution
now at the present time
uh... i have uh... and produced
a new resolution
uh... which would make that backing off
of trade relations with czechoslovakia
mandatory
in other words uh... they would be
broken off by congressional action
now there have been some other moves
made for example
prohibiting the airplane traffic
uh... from prague the capital of
czechoslovakia and other points in that
country
from prime across to the occupied zone
served germany this i think is hurting
them at least uh... i think it is what
do you think dot
that seemed to me it seems that there
have been done
because the gimmick connections with the
west
very important to behavior
uh...
cut you off
and that's costing them money costing
them money
going definitely and uh...
there you can not
context
the rest of the same way as the could
because most of the other alliance uh...
americans and others
uh... sculpting wants to get the
slovakia too
now who are wired doctor was always
seized in the first place
was he sees as a hostage
of in my opinion
uh... the purpose walls to having as a
hostage
for a future purposes
and that though some of those purposes
whether they want from last ah...
whether they want to hear you know if i
were one of these incidents
they were complaining
and are still complaining of the uh...
book so the voice of america
and then you but i'll pass the time
developing from uh... munich
uh... erected to czechoslovakia and i
say i would urge to intimidate harass
and intimidate and perhaps proof
premium is
these broadcasts would be stopped
bacteria and congressman obstacle to ask
you
you are a
presumption
especially the second one is it is uh...
footballs that
excuse that order will be a part orbit
and general policy all that the united
states over whether it is intended just
for the purpose of helping two thirty
that mister okies
well doctor papa neck
uh... one of the resolution
uh... is directed at the specific case
operating this american citizen and
correspondent
uh... it is the settlement of my
colleagues in congress i'm sure
uh... that this day a test case
and that it set a precedent
and that player ever in any of the iron
curtain countries under the domination
of the soviet union
free citizens are imprisoned unjustly
that in the future of the red regime of
that government will be given notice so
that we are going to take every step
possible to protect them i'd hope that
the resolution
in adopted will conduct every case
and uh... that they would not be any
exceptions
well that's exactly what we hope it will
do
uh... the resolution as you understand
uh... calls for the cutting off of
exports from
this country from the united states
to your fatherland project was locked up
uh... biaxin out the commerce department
in other words the cutting off of all
permits
to export goods from this country
likewise
uh... the treasury department which has
charge up imports from czechoslovakia to
this country
would prohibit
any transactions
that would permit trade uh... prompt
echoes the rocket to the united states
so it would be a complete blockade up
trading either way
despondency
when uh... dental appt
life etc
tremendously that people of
czechoslovakia
whose morale luda b
strengthened
to misbehave cease the communist regime
and they have strong resistance and then
czechoslovakia now dr
definitely their needs
uh... yep i would say that over ninety
percent of the people of opal's betty
jean
but uh... that
uh... sec
jails are full
that today are executions at practicum
every week
that uh... uh... the forced labor camps
are for
but about three hundred thousand people
out there without proof that babies any
of these things
alarmed by the hair explanation of that
doctor because we and congress
and certainly the american people
do not want to penalize
the people of czechoslovakia
we feel that they are the victims of
communist aggression
however we feel that uh... if this step
is taken
and of those people out the resistance
of the underground the anti communist
forces in czechoslovakia they will be
willing to make whatever sacrifices
needed in order to strike directly at
the communist regime is panic
they will be happy to have to cancel
and got to be no also
that uh...
economic relations
spade innovations
doing bit last month
or the last ten years that have to help
i mean he
portant the soviet military build-up
because it was a lot to important on the
raw materials and now i a congressman
after all delegates is an individual
and what i meant to be honest whether
this is going to be effective in getting
them and out
values when do you think otis will be
released well mister
delay that is a sixty four dollar
question so far as mister elvis himself
his concern
and as you say he is a few months
and uh...
we want to freeing him we do we do not
want to partially buchanan who predicted
just how long of a impressive when do
you think you'll be released almost
reviewer i believe when this blockade
becomes a fact
i believe that he will be freed within a
few weeks within three or four weeks
from now than you think there's a good
chance to be a little bit free i think
there is a good chance of the of the
free however
i think that he will be freed when
moscow
tells the rep regime of czechoslovakia
different now thank you so much for
being with us packaged
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching telescope laws
doctor john for product
and
mister william bradford curie
our distinguished guest was the
honorable ok armstrong
congressman from missouri
one of the most interesting monuments in
new york isn't herald square
it's a replica of the talk of medieval
days which was simply a striking the
earth
there was no doubt
meltdowns thrust tolling bell whom rock
creek park
uh...
non
how
and went back
in the distant past
the worldwatch
was first applied to a timepiece when
the time could be read rather than her
and way back in eighteen sixty six
at eighty five years ago
the first lol gene watts was made
created to the ideals that forever
and whatever the name long gene
would be placed
only on the finest watches which
mechanical skills could produce
how well successive generations of
launching watch makers have followed
this idea
is reflected by the public on is
launching watchers have one
ten world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals
and highest honors for accuracy from the
leading government observatory
the ball game watch is not being shown
by fine jewelers throughout the land
in every detail of performance and
beauty
the perfection which today's launching
watches have attain
it's a fair statement
throughout the world
no other name on a watch means so much
as launching
the world's most honored watch
preemie our product
of the loan gene but na watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of authors
of the highest etc
this is right now
reminding you that our program is
brought to a
three times weekly
so want to join us again wednesday
evening
at the same time
but on seeing protestants
that television journalism by two of
them so they are
broadcast on behalf of
launching
the world's most ahmedabad
what not
listing with companion for the world are
daunting
so then service broncos to go
by more than four thousand leading to
others
who proudly displayed the emblem
agency bought on teamwork
kaam hota luxury promised
a television journal of the important
issues of the offer
roughly elaborate monday wednesday and
friday
presentation outlet on jane what's not
watch company
playground bomb jane the world's most
honored watch
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world dot i don t
good evening this is frank not
mail and reduce octal additives for this
edition of the ron jane prosto
larry of this error c_b_s_ news
correspondent
at august texture chief editorial writer
for the new yorker of review
our distinguished guests of this evening
is the reverend doctor edward l art s
pastor of the national presbyterian
church of washington d_c_
during this christmas but i think it's
only fair to say that
very few administrations in the white
house uh... underscored the place of the
church in our national life
as much as president eisenhower has
most of us
a familiar with the faces of the men
around the president
but feel once had a great opportunity
to meet the presidential pastor
no matter who and president eisenhower
listens
every sunday
dot blots and am i right in
thinking that uh...
president eisenhower has been
spearheading a
something of a religious revival in this
country
it would seem to be corrected mister
seward to report that to in america
today we uh...
observe two trends on the one hand it we
have been
participants in the spectators in what
might be an a
described as mark
deterioration and uh... say cultural say
on the other hand in america we are
experiencing
a great moral resurgence and spiritual
renaissance
and uh...
the president united states is it seems
to me is by his
personal example and his emphasis
they're becoming any symbol of the
uh... incipient spurt spiritual
renaissance of our times which it is a
retired asst
decadent on one side and research done
over
i think they're they're the parallel
each other their simultaneous aspects of
our debris life
their pressures uh... which probably
operate uh... against one another what
what i thought of assigned to this
decadence
dr lawson
i think you that juvenile delinquency
for example the um... height incidence
of crime the insecurity that are all or
homes the
fragile of personalities the frequency
of uh... cycle neurotic his supporters
it and things of the sword the senses
insecurity in frustration amongst
uh...
all these years
evidence is it seems to me in the come
true teachers i think part of our
emphasis on money-making and anna
materialistic aspects of our life might
also be emphasizes the evidence on that
pant on the on that site
but on the other hand it seems to me
we're
it in a rising tide of uh... spiritual
recovery
we uh...
notice the increased uh...
participation in religious activities on
the part name and there's a new
seriousness and earnestness on the part
of college and university students the
quality of the religious leaders it
seems to me is markedly improved since
uh... world war
too
either the sale of the bible the
spective religious books amongst the
best sellers of month in month out the
reappearance of masti evangelism and it
will be active religion on radio and
television the through because of the
uh...
fears of all the facts of war the types
of atomic
but barbara
partially there's only one of the
reasons it would seem to me that uh...
through the some of his does arise out
consensus
fear of the communist fear of nuclear
devices a of a new world war
uh... certainly some of it is due to the
fact that
that we have discovered the in aptitude
of other solutions uh... to the world's
needs and perhaps more basically than
anything else it it is a deep wistful
listen the heart and soul of uh... men
and women to be at home with their maker
for whom there so was designed
but part of this revival is alive if i
imagine
renewed church-going more regular habit
among families and people bus tour of
the president i think of me it seems to
me there's an unprecedented lehigh uh...
church attendance throughout the united
states today not only months to not
owning one religious group amongst all
religious groups
certainly the president has uh...
set a great example for regularity
church attendance he just doesn't miss
church was that i did you do have an
opportunity to meet the the president
before he entered the white house yes i
have met the president uh... before he
entered the white house and
knew him first as a general thing army
and of course uh...
as mister with every american who served
in the european two three four i was
under his command one time
had been recommended to become the staff
chapman for the occupation forces in
germany a position which was not
uh... and uh... i returned to america
for another position shortly after
general eisenhower became chief of staff
so i didn't have the privilege of being
a staff chapel let me ask you this
question do you have any uh... political
bias dot gales and uh...
david one-party available
methodist late how did you vote in
nineteen fifty two
in nineteen fifty two during the
election campaign missus osman ironic
lecture toward the middle east we
visited does some twenty educational
institutions in egypt and syria and
lebanon and jordan and israel and
elsewhere so the time
did not vote then
i pay taxes in california i've paid
taxes in the district of columbia and
i'm one of those dis franchised
americans who've simply cannot vote
eyes and say this that hidden at the
nation's capital
we in the church tried to minister as
best we can
people as
people with common religious needs
robbins and people as democrats and
three
public in this
and we believe that washington is is a
city in the world where
prayer in the ministry religion is
deeply needed and i should say that i'm
among those persons today who
tremendously hopes the president
eisenhower will succeed
and be a good president of the united
states
stockdale's witness the christmas season
i wonder whether i could ask your
opinion of it recently have been stated
in a very powerful seven the christmas
has been sentimental eyes here in the
united states do you feel that do you
think that something we ought to fight
against
it certainly is true that there has been
a a great deal of sentimentality
attached to uh...
christmas impression over emphasis on
some of the secular manifestations of
the christmas tied observance which have
grown up around the real meaning
uh... it seems to me that the mission
all the church today should be too
keep the real meaning of christmas
allied namely
that it is the commemoration of the
birth of our roared jesus christ it is
the celebration of uh...
the incarnation of
glob coming into the life of man in the
form of
pieces of massacres
if you know they've got to tell someone
you write your sermons unconscious of
any influence you might be wheeling or
exerting on the president
in your parish
eyes should think that any man who
ministers to a congregation in
washington
whether or not the president united
states was in the congregation
must be deeply aware of the
possible impact which is words either in
prayers were in sermons might have upon
anne persons who would be in his
congregation alliance must confess that
i have not consciously prepared any
sermon for any one person's yukio
sermons to any
current news item or headline i've
preached the gospel of jesus christ is i
don't
understand it have been tossed a tight
fight we nancy eight with clarity
dies should say that no sermon is
prepared to point out a particular
current issue but that if anne
um... moral or spiritual loan
implication that uh... is uh... relevant
at the moment but i do not dodge it i
face it clearly and speak
do what i believe to be the
truth of the gospel as pertains to that
adelphia subject
okay in reading the bible do you find
that some young people read it too much
you might say for the poetry in the
literature other than that they don't
pay enough
attention to the religious truth
i think sometimes that
the maybe said to be true of young
people but i think it is increasingly
true that young people as well as others
are finding
the bible to bt the word of god and they
find god communicate he himself
to them through the words of the bible
another doctor alvin have you had
decided on
your topic
when the president listens to you at
this christmastime
well on them
last sunday december
nineteenth
uh... the president was in the church
service
and the subject of my sermon was the
christmas a messege is too
and i used is text and i think it
overlooked text is sometimes the
christmas season the text of the herald
to the shepherd
fear not
for before i bring you good tidings of
great joy
which should be too long people
seems to me in this
fear ridden world
that is one of the messages which the
christmastime should bring to us with
deep meaning
dot gautam economists are saying that
we're in for a year of uh...
of great prosperity do you think that
uh... religion will fare as well as a
uh... material well-being in the coming
my prediction is that uh... religion is
going to can
to annual on the ascendancy and is going
to absorb a great deal more of uh...
more time and attention on the park
americans i believe that
and the mir the track back to church in
itself may not be sufficient it
certainly will
uh... the real test of it will come when
people discover and those were
christians that there is a cross in
there
fate fitted beans
sacrifices means service and that it
costs
something to be a christian
but if i believe the coming year will be
a year of uh...
deepening of the spiritual lives of
our people and a
recovery
uh... under reappraisal of our spiritual
baseball delayed by a pair of christmas
scenes that you've known dr lawson
for me and i should think for most
americans this would be a very very
christmas it is the first in
with many years when marika man of
actually not been engaged in armed
certainly for me to happy one and one
ten years ago when
i was attempting to ministered to
men in uniform who were then engaged in
the
battle of the bonds
i remember with great vividness
administering
communion on
christmas eve two men
who've doubtless received it that night
for there last time
certainly is cause for thanksgiving
this christmas
but i feel so we know that uh... the
president attendees
attends church regularly but to other
members of the cabinet and other
administration uh... tender you know a
national presbyterian church it it is
true that a great many of them attend
the national presbyterian church in
addition to the president uh...
secretary and missus dallas are part of
our congregation
secretary mike
k of the interior postmaster general
somerfield mr j_ edgar hoover mr walter
williams
we have two or three assistance attorney
general
question umer military officials
justices of the supreme court judges and
others but
i think it needs to be sent to the
american people that work in tune is a
deeply religious city
and it's a good city
at least it's just as good as the people
who are sent to it
bhaiya
rest of the people of the united states
you don't think that washington needs
religion more than other part of the
country then
ashes say not more than other parts of
the country it needs religion for the
same reason all-americans and all people
whom god has created
need religion thank you very much that
yeltsin
minister in the shadow here tonight
the opinions expressed on the lounging
call the scope where those of the
speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching hospital closed larry
lesser and august texture
our distinguished guest was the reverend
doctor edward elkhart nelson pastor of
the national press the very interaction
of washington d_c_
an important contribution was largely
much later that night at the time to
find a
for us to originate the idea that's for
us to venture bigtime with identical
watches
i've known and proven act
dot owens lament the side they are
launching created a series of new
watches accurate second by second
which time to s
and the hundredth of a second
in observed retest these watches show
degree of accuracy greater than that
required but all international sports
and concept association for timing world
req
the embarrassment of millions of dollars
and years of time into the fallopian
tube ever fired timepieces as a result
of a new what's making principles and
left
that it may be possible to give greater
accuracy and dependability to all
launching watch
doing the laundry and watch which you'll
not wear on your wrist
so when next you buy a lot out of
yourself or as an important get
remember you made by known or probably
give along came up
for as little as seventy one fifty
launching in the world's most art watch
the world's most on ticket
premium product of the loan she must
know what's happening
since eighteen sixty six maker of waters
of the highest debt
this is frank night reminding you that
machine and with no water
are sold in service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to a
who proudly display their family
agency bought on jane what norwalk
acknowledging what knowledge or leslie
at most a perpetual motion talk created
by the fuqra at most problems without
climbing without electricity
power only five variations and the
temperature of the atmosphere
up-close product of the court
division of launching left off
vision
hahaha
all
plunging watches at one ten welfare
grand prizes twenty eight gold medals
and bar honors for accuracy than any
other time
argue the world's most honored watches
made and guaranteed by the logging would
not want company
time for the ellen james bond
television journalist impartial with
harshal u_s_
presentation of the largely what all i
have
later on
launching
the world's most holocaust
and what
distinguished companion for the world on
its own
through the evening
mail you introduce our co-editors for
this edition of the laundry in chrome
usko
mister william bradford hwy editor of
the american mercury
mr paul martin
washington bureau chief of the gannett
news service
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable richard b russell
united state senator from georgia
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
senator russell ali ends of course no
issue is a distinguished religion
who is now a principal contender for the
democratic nomination for the presidency
and tonight we welcome some of your user
how i how long have you been in the
senate
i came to the senate did january
thirteenth nineteen and thirty three
uh... almost twenty years
unfortunate now senator al audience
would like to know just where you stand
in the political spectrum are you and
you'd be reserved
well i call myself a middle-of-the-road
of mister hewitt
uh... one of my newspaper friends once
label me as a sixty percent new dealer
during the
administration of president franklin d
roosevelt
now are you a critique of the present
administration
well after the side of some of the
things that this administration has done
i have supported the overall great deal
of the uh...
legislative uh...
if requests of this administration
anywhere you sent to you said we were
asked for the presidency of the jury
jeffersonian democrat now
we haven't heard much about that lady
can you tell us what a jeffersonian
democrats spies into mutual few people
proudly paula
but gibson stood for the fundamental
french police procedure for although the
democratic party the unmanned rejection
out they can surely
uh... johnson stood for the rights of
the states
as being protection of the rights of the
individual countrymen
a bad federal power
he also stood for
absolutely incorruptible in the
administration of them or circa russell
we haven't had much of what he stood for
in the democratic national platform the
last twenty years i was
well we're everyone would rather false
from the
fundamental principles of jefferson but
that
thank that their millions of democrats
throughout the country that still it hit
to the jeffersonian
approach those articulated ever state of
the union nasser man
in your twenty years and incidentally i
believe you are one of the youngest man
who is a candidate for the president
said now you're only fifty four and two
that ran up and you know you've been in
congress almost twenty years as a chance
to ensure that governor mistake before
that
classic god
in general
did you support most of the legislation
most of the new deal legislation and
under president roosevelt
i think that the trend is estimated that
supported six percent of it was about
right
and uh... you don't have a bigger share
part of this program the rural education
program
farm program than uh...
biamby a large number of the measures it
was broke the net and the south as as
generally prospered under that
and under that legislation has not yes i
think that that's out there soon is is
the prosperity of the salvage increased
greatly in the last few twenty years or
your definition of a jeffersonian
democrat
that you're going to have a considerable
revision
say the nineteen forty eight democratic
national platform where you couldn't
uh... the an honest exponent of the
party for president
there are some features of the nineteen
hundred and forty-eight platform that
yeah i think the contrary to give shawn
french food
not although not all of that well
platform was a democratic voters always
been that
body of the people
and the body of individual rights and
liberties and water that's good for the
rights of the state practice left except
in practice here and we've got a
democratic president why don't we have
had for
for about twenty years now
now if you were president senator
russell would you feel that you have the
inherent powers under the constitution
that mister truman says he has
to seize the steel industry other
newspapers a radio stations or anything
else lowest-common-denominator out of
this night of the endurance power
dozens of them on the wall another
government of maine
and where there's a statute disconnected
by congress just available to you
it's highly preferable to use that
stature rather than to relying on as
nablas today managed in here and powers
course we must remember that the at the
power to cc
is radio the press so i didn't steal of
plans
if that exists in the bedroom he also
has a policy usually begin
and labor men would get the around a
long time in inviting some major shift
in me
at the desk of the good news they do
know the secretary-treasurer of the
union now that you're telling our
audience that you are somewhat this
period
that the president's action i would much
prefer to the burden to the following
the steps that they fit leased to get it
that could have been employed to resolve
this matter without resorting
seeing here in polish had heard that the
other questions has been said i don't
think mister mckenna dictator
but i think that date is that could well
be the blueprint for some and or you
might see in a world of government day
in the future on the strategy mainly
national emergency clause of the taft
hartley act
yes you know that all
a statue of which are having to bend the
author of when the original draft bill
passed which gave me
present the power to uh...
perceives
flannel facility in this country that
or refused to uh...
supplier
of contracts are necessary for the
defense effort
uh... robin purple could anybody wanna
bold and provide the standard if she had
they provide for the method of repayment
and don't leave all of those matters up
in the area is just uh...
matter in this thing a billion here and
polished character senator russell of
this matter of inherent part you know
it's another southerner
steinhardt curved texas uh... used to be
the attorney general who ruled and told
the president that he had in here for
some of the constitution
and time parks now in the supreme court
which would be the court a last resort
if anybody ever wanted to test this
theory of inherent powers wellness mob
negotiate juliet in sports when she was
being the best
had been a number of british agent which
majority this pennsylvania court handed
down that did not jive with my
construction of the constant remain
unstable
the senate after all now you are a very
active candidate for the democratic
nomination for the presidency and so
rapidly we'd like some of your views on
specific issues
now number one
about how many delegates do you expect
to have at the convention in in chicago
i hope to have a
as many as four hundred and i'm quite
confident that i will have more than
three hundred
and and and and i think that our insist
that you can use to do you expect to
have this
support from northern states however
some support from northern states
uh... i will have some delegates
i love the book of mulch for disney in
the southern states
now the delegate as a delegate one vote
count as much as you know that that man
is a lack of a politician do you think
that it is not possible
for a southerner to receive the
democratic nomination for the press
published yet don't like to think that
after ninety years of being intervened
and the democratic party has loyally
supported the
gave been loyally supported by the south
over that period at the a man to be
discriminated against because we have
been born on the wrong side of it
philandering show them a chance in life
that brings us to the principal question
sir with your always ask and share with
our audience would like to hear your
views on
a traditional police's is richard
garcetti pc
and that of course is one of the things
that uh... is addicted reasons if you're
addicted to in the northern cities to
take it just what is your view on a ppc
almost hit the p_c_ as many as seven
issue a section of a shoe goes way
for the very heart of our markham system
uh... made it go
the thirty eight point which is the
federal government
has a pop
to pass a fund employment
and fun promotion
and upon employment policies
and they also in the matter of
discharges from involved
now i do not believe the free enterprise
system can't possibly jewish
if uh... we did have a whole lot of
federal agents running all over the
country
appealing older men chose not to taking
the read their minds because after all
it is a matter of the focus of call
police what was in the man's mind when
he died this
individual rather than the other
although i leave my group earlier rather
than other group
i do not think i think that that will
eventually result
in now the nationalization of all
businessmen judge in this country if we
have a passion
of compulsory jail sentence
iffy pc
that put a man in prison because he
employs one man instead of a above
another nicer shortly lost american
lives
currently and that's a very important
issue but uh... well we have time
reluctant discussion about foreign
policy
following your review where the chairman
of the joint
uh... senate armed services and foreign
relations committee that uh...
conducted the hearings though
president truman's firing of general
macarthur
well he went into that very exhausted
lied about so many words which has to
about seven weeks of morning and
afternoon high nitrogen thrown out why
did you ever get around to write a
report telling the american people how
you felt about whether the president
should or should not by general
macarthur
well i'll tell you about that every
american citizen is made up his mind
already
there was no region there for that
committed to showdown in trouble for
three weeks
in writing the report which would have
been a divided fourth been impossible
fallen through the green
and it would have guessed let it be
alert to the
flames of bitterness it spread over the
country on both sides of that issue
review committee could restore
democratic system and if we have had
with the the billionaire and his
judgment
and a there was no good that i saw it
could blow from the committee
undertaking five division
to say well of joe mccarthy was right
over the joint chiefs ride on the
president's percent to write a review of
the has been a great pleasure to have
you with us tonight thank you very much
thank you for talking to be on this
probe
editorial board for distribution of the
laundry in commerce co juan's
mister william bradford here we
mr paul martin
our distinguished guests with the
honorable richard b russell united state
senator from georgia
the progress of watch making over the
years
has been enormously stimulated by
competitions between watch makers
arranged by some of the leading national
observatories
you should know that a first prize one
in an observatory accuracy contest
is one of the highest honors to which a
watch manufacturer can aspire
you should also know if you are
contemplating the purchase of a very
fine watch
but the record of laundry in observateur
accuracy competitions is unsurpassed
year after year since eighteen seventy
eight
long g_m_ watchers have won first prize
after first prize for promoters
deck watches
pocket watches and wrist watches
and of great interest to you
the present accuracy record for wrist
watches at the great no shackled
government observateur eight is held by
a long gene
the world's most armored watch
if you wish to all just about the finest
watch made anywhere in the world
your choice might well be laundry
the world's most armored watch
when a rope and the world's fair grand
prizes
twenty eight gold medal awards
and innumerable honors for accuracy in
fields of precise timing
lunging
the world's most on our block
premier product of the laundry britain
or watch company
teens sixty six
maker of watchers of the highest
character
this is david remorse
speaking for your regular post frank
night
inviting you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene chronicle
a television journal off the important
issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of long gene
the world's most vulnerable
and with nora
distinguished companion to the world
armored laundry
sold and servers from coast to coast
by more than four thousand levi jewelers
all proudly display the emblem
agency for a long train with norwalk